[Music]
all right let's rock you ready oh yeah
where the hell's this beard you where is
he hey folks here we are we might be
drunk we're back it's the holiday season
oh wait when's this come out in March
early January oh okay we could do some
we can do some resolutions hey I like it
now when do you have the new year cut
off yeah Happy New Year I think early on
I think you get the first week or so
yeah and then after that it's like what
are we doing okay it's a new year it's a
new year we got it we've got some eggnog
I can't think I can't think of eggnog
without David tell's elf come bit
um you can't look at eggnog without
thinking it's elf come because of Dave
sign of a good bit when you can't not
think of it during when you're just
hanging out
I said it before Todd Berry anytime he
sees a guy with a neck tattoo you forgot
to not do that I'll be smart I got a
really good nose I just put in my coffee
uh [ __ ] it's been open before
he's like a 2K on this guy he's a blood
house he's got so much sugar it's
probably fine ah
that's what they said about Ralphie May
all right okay
um
tastes good in the coffee here I'm the
eggnog expert so do you load that with
booze also in that or does it come
loaded no no I'll get you more booze now
beer juice running late so we're
starting with some eggnog that's
perfection
I need more uh eggnog in my life oh yeah
I mean it's like why why only once I
guess the once a year is good for eggnog
it would be weird to have it in July
yeah you see a dude in July with egg
nugget it's a little real Rich milk was
a bad choice yeah I have I just bought a
quart I've already finished it but it's
crazy to think like that size of eggnog
is in my body now drinking throughout
the week
little BC the morning started right
Christ whoo
the poor [ __ ]
uh so I'm watching mad man I'm
re-watching it oh best show so good and
uh that's why you're in a drinking mood
yeah maybe you're right
but there's that one scene I don't want
to give too much away but that the
alcoholic guy pissed his pants Oh Freddy
Robson yes Freddy the whole show I
didn't realize he's just pouring
screwdrivers and [ __ ] like you know they
won't go with breakfast huh but I didn't
catch it until seeing it again now that
I know he whizzes himself one of my
favorite scenes in the I don't know if
we ever pulled it we might have played
it on the show but the scene where Pete
tries to [ __ ] over spoiler tries to [ __ ]
over Don Yeah by being like you know
this man is a a deserter at best you
know oh yeah and and Bert Cooper just
looks at him and was just like who cares
he goes this man this country was
founded with men with much worse records
yes and he goes in and even if what you
say is true it's in the company's best
interest to forget about this yeah it's
such a great [ __ ] moment great moment
now this is a real alcoholic move my dad
does the old oh yeah is it spinach did
he ever do it to you oh
hahaha
a little Subway handrail on that one
yikes
this is good
oh yeah it's actually it is hitting the
spot is it normal is an eggnog usually
rum or whiskey or does it not really
matter it started with rum that was the
original but this works now it's Rye
yeah right like Rye better yeah
mmm so I got the peat here I'm not sure
this is the one he insults Peggy and
then Don puts him in his place no no no
no no it's uh put in Bert Cooper I mean
I basically just said the scene I don't
know if we need to do it you know what
you guys gotta see someone showed me
this the other day you ever see Mark
McGrath from Sugar Ray snap on some
[ __ ] kid no it's one of the funniest
clips I hope I'm not building it up too
much this guy's out of his mind so is
this is this the one I don't know let's
see sugar gay yeah he calls him sugar
gay
I said that
oh I didn't say anything can I be smart
yeah did I say anything did she say
something no I did not say anything
ah good stood his own there no it keeps
going
I've never seen this suck your [ __ ]
face
2004. I don't know it was a different
time
that's all it took to set him off yeah
well he's heard it before
this guy like when he discovers Twitter
keeps going oh does yeah look how long
that is oh yeah
[Applause]
[ __ ] choke your [ __ ] face
these guys stop standing right here
it's almost like he's angry at himself
he's like this is like insults you'll
never make it in this business he's like
why did we rhyme our name with gay yeah
it was a layup wow wasn't he the host of
extra yeah he left touring for that [ __ ]
wow he probably could have made Bank on
the road yeah oh yeah and he's a hunk of
a guy oh yeah they had a couple good
songs
you're all right
I just wanna fly I think he just wants
to fight
like who's that for who's he doing that
go to the end because it gets crazy
oh you're right like this I just want to
fly off the handle this guy right here
over here
right here
wow [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] you in the ass this
kid's got a poster he wanted a signature
what a 180 this kid had
what do you say he goes through nothing
but my little fart
what's the language it's not exactly
roast battle pictures too
[Applause]
look at you you got some new fans over
here Mark I love sugar right now
see this
um
[Applause]
[Laughter]
snapping
he's just he's probably just a fan yeah
I know he thought he was being funny I
thought he was like a playful roast yo
beard you in the house oh you got to
take a [ __ ] oh here he goes anyway if I
snapped on every fan who called me gay I
would be I'd be a busy guy he'd be an
MMA fighter yeah yeah exactly am I'm gay
man I went out I got [ __ ] I got kind
of house last night I'm hurting I I
admittedly I text uh Peters and Norman
this morning I was like how do you guys
feel about an IV app while we drank just
to get me back on my feet but I hit the
gym I sucked it up I feel all right but
uh this will help this will help but I
did a benefit last night the uh uh the
Ally Coalition uh the singer Jack
Antonoff puts it on it was that
screwball was a big thing wow he's a
huge comedy guy right yeah he was really
cool and he's a really talented man he's
a really talented guy but that's a big
room yeah it was big it was a cool show
but bigley was on it nice Jackie Novak
oh yeah and some musicians I'm like with
I did I don't know anything about about
modern music so I didn't my friend John
Weisberg with me and he's like that's
Phoebe Bridgers and I was like I don't
know are you a complete bag I know
that's what I thought yeah no singer
it's a singer and she's like oh and then
he's like she and then she went out got
like the hugest Ovation I'm like I'm I'm
out of touch she was amazing they might
not know who we are either yeah but
they're way bigger that's true she's
like a huge star apparently I mean uh
yeah and burning Bridgers all right and
then yeah we got sauce There was a pizza
guy from razza a Jersey City Place
unreal and then we uh it was one of the
things we kept drinking through the
night so we ended up at a bar in the uh
all I remember is we end up at a bar in
the West Village wrecked saw Jared freed
there that's hilarious and then uh some
people recognized me at the bar so I'm
just getting wasted with these people
and I all I remember is them being like
where were you and I said I did a
benefit and I was so drunk I was like
what was it for and I was like Teenage
abortion
it was through a teenager boy and then
we started singing the Hanukkah Song and
we walked them because we kept singing
to Hanukkah we kept going O.J Simpson
that was great not a Jew
Paul Newman correct half yeah Cody horns
have Jewish Paul Newman's have two there
it is put them together what a fine
looking Jew that was a that that the
great song song changed the game it's
I'll put it up against any Christmas
song that's all we have
Sandler what uh where you been man
uh I've been around they just moved
yeah
um figuring things out you started
without you yeah I'm sorry about that I
mean
uh we're in Queens Upper East Side ah
sorry
sorry I heard every upper east side's
got every [ __ ] trade now yeah I got
the queue up there now and uh De Niro
just got robbed up there I saw that yeah
worst thing that happened to him since
Little Fockers too
and the comedian oh man that was rough
we were in that oh yeah our headshots
were in it yeah someone said that to me
and they're like you're in the movie I'm
like what I wasn't so as I've been that
surprised since I have a headshot since
Kennedy all right
the joke works though I thought it was
floundering no but yeah no these are
really hitting us no we uh that's crazy
you got robbed yeah I was gonna buy a
extra in one of his movies or something
no it was by a lady who's a Serial
robber and she they caught her under the
tree literally came downstairs she's
under the tree and the cops ran in damn
that if he's got kids I gotta be like
Santa's a woman ah no because women just
take yeah
she's 30 years old and uh she had a
string of robberies damn
it's weird I know it's kind of like I
mean bad Santa's one of my favorite
holidays oh great movie great comedy
there she is Shanice
30. so she robbed his house or robbed
him under the tree she knew but he was
home for it he was home no it was the
narrowest place I don't think so imagine
being a robber and De Niro walks out
yeah that's gotta feel pretty rough
robbing me
do you think that's like as a robber do
you think that's like kind of cool or
are you like ah [ __ ] I love I love
Casino yeah how do you feel do you think
I would have gone for the Oscars [ __ ]
that [ __ ] the uh the presents get the
gold yeah once you see an Academy Award
in there you're like ah [ __ ] yeah this
might be a news story I know but here
like is this Polansky is this uh Harvey
who could be anybody it's definitely not
Polanski oh yeah he's over here
where'd he go Spain like 20 years I'll
be like we should we should stop raping
right
that's really where you get uh you
really can just go or like where
Switzerland is another one
where do you live I guess you just go to
Europe it used to be Mexico and I was
going to like go to Mexico yeah I feel
like that's over yeah yeah I mean Luis
said in his new special he goes so I've
been in France for the last two years or
whatever for obvious reasons so I guess
that's where he went as well yeah I
guess that's the spot
yeah me too Riviera
the French really uh
they made a state of the women made a
statement they were remember me that was
your whole thing instead of me too they
did not make they did not me which is
like we gotta we should take a road trip
when the French president mittaran died
his widow sat next to his mistress at
the funeral they sat side by side it was
like this is what we do yeah yeah we
both have claim to this guy's life
Carmella never would have said next to a
Gooma
no they're more I mean dude how about
macron his wife is like what's his
teacher that's like a porno what his
wife with this [ __ ] teacher like in
college I think so yeah she's like at
least 20 years older than him wow
held it together yeah good looking lady
but I mean she is she was his teacher oh
she got teacher Vibes yeah
um
whoa whoa yeah I mean he's definitely
younger
women love when a guy's dating an older
lady or married or they're like oh
that's so sweet and you're like shut up
just because it makes you feel better
better
well that's how it goes this is this is
heading dude ah the problem is you can
drink 17 of these then you don't [ __ ]
for a month yeah all the milk and cream
eggnog in her eye oh yeah oh yeah
yeah this is definitely uh it's a it's a
festive drink yeah it's a time of year
what is there anything else I guess like
warm Spiced Rum is really good
mulled wine yeah mold warm alcoholic
drinks are kind of underrated underrated
what was the one you said we got to try
the wine one I think that was the the
mulled wine yeah yeah we haven't tried
that yet though you can definitely do
mulled wine tastes like a data prep and
we can like fortify it with like brandy
or whiskey
make it like really hell punch
then there's a hot cider I love Hot
ciders yeah it's nice nice like herbs in
there like star anise and cinnamon oh
they have a little bourbon what is this
delicious hot buttered rum whoa that was
a gay thing my nipples are hard
holy hell
oh my god oh no
where were you last weekend San
Francisco baby oh did you go to sotomori
I did oh dude love that town I had a
great time that town is magical you
didn't hear all the news stories like
they'll cut your head off they'll steal
your watch it was great oh it's one of
my favorite cities because you know what
as New Yorkers on the it's on the west
coast that's as close as we get yes
exactly you can take a walk that great
bookstore City Lights City Lights dude
yeah I'm just I just walked into the
pier every day I went to Little Italy
then I went to Chinatown and I'm just
walking up and down the hills and my ass
hurt that was from the Castro that's
just a great time
crowds were great it's dude I love SF
Essa the Sun was shining and it was kind
of chilly it was a perfect perfect
weather the whole thing was great yeah
great food the Chowder oh the Chowder
got dim sum we gotta go uh some you know
Yang Sing that's the spot there oh
really awesome yeah my boy Adam Swig is
like the mayor there he he's literally
like Lebowski he just looks like
Lebowski oh and he just takes me to all
these spots and uh he he's taking me to
uh he took me to a Giants game last time
I was there [ __ ] great maybe the most
beautiful ballpark I know and it's right
City it's gorgeous gorgeous yeah SF has
got some problems but like it is a
beautiful city I open with that I was
like I went shopping today it was all
under a thousand so I got it for free
and they were like he knows about us you
know Cobbs is an epic weekend and your
your photos on the wall is it yeah you
got to it's like you know Geraldo and
tell you I'm honored yeah wow it's fun
seeing your peers on the wall because
you know coming up it was like oh
there's John Panetta Oh there's uh you
know Louis CK or there's yeah Chris Rock
and now it's us I'm like oh they show
the Pinette photo it's room for three
more
yeah Legend he's a legend oh yeah funny
guy but now it's like soda it's you know
all these guys we know that's fun yeah
it's fun I saw soda at the airport the
other day it's fun just like Thursday
when you go to the airport you're like
who am I gonna say nothing better than
how much at the airport yeah that is the
best it is really fun you feel like
you're both like paratroopers like where
are you headed you know you're like
you're both going to battle I'm going to
Denver oh I'm going to Phoenix
yeah it is the best man we veto and I
fly into uh
we're flying to uh Tacoma last weekend
and six hour flight yeah it was a crying
baby the entire way it didn't stop
yeah wow
brutal six hours how far back are you in
first we were in first uh veter2 Peter
Vito got the upgrade baby yeah I don't
know it kind of bugged me seeing those
feet dangling
you know you could use a Delta comfort
[Laughter]
it's funny when there's a tiny dude in
first yeah right there's a baby in first
that's crazy that should be part of
first you don't have to deal with the
baby that's true that is true Cuba
adults first you want to see the flight
attendant just walk over like hey can I
just see the baby and just put a
chloroform oh my God just knock it out
look I used to fly with my ex-girlfriend
had a tiny dog we'd give it Benadryl and
that thing would be like it was a yappy
Chihuahua was the biggest [ __ ] of a dog
like something about Mary yes exactly
and uh it'd be like dead you get to pet
it and poke it and it was great why not
give a baby a Benadryl that's all give
it a half
you're gonna be a great dad
he's a good dad for the community yeah
thank you the community thanks him drug
your baby I got on a plane next to a
baby and the mother handed me a little
Ziploc baggie and it had a candy in it
and uh earplugs
oh she's like I'm sorry wow yeah wow
because she knew what was gonna happen
see I like that because I'm an anxious
guy and if I bait was crying I would be
freaking out when you hand her a
sleeping mask you start masturbating oh
my God I'm sorry too I have a problem
there's a Benadryl for you
I'm sorry for that one
we uh you know we had we don't know
we're getting so I'm getting Sauced on
the flight they do those Tip-Top
old-fashioned cans oh I love those so I
started getting smashed on the flight
and uh Vita and I keep doing whenever
the baby goes well Vito and I just got
going
and I posted a couple of them on
Instagram stories and someone responds
um you know because I'm doing the Q a
thing they respond uh you know it's
really cruel to make fun of a baby for
that because uh the altitude really
hurts their ears and they're in a lot of
pain I was like isn't it more cruel to
take a baby on a plane then oh good boy
come at me it's a [ __ ] vacation he's
never gonna remember
right great Point unless it's a funeral
or something hopefully it's the babies
oh my God
yeah in which case the baby needs to be
there for the eulogy what like yeah
exactly I've never been to a baby
funeral do they have a teeny tiny casket
will you save some money there oh that's
true that's nice that's something I've
always wondered do bigger people pay
more for clothes because it is more
fabric I think so yeah you do
all right I mean it's only fair I guess
it isn't fair because you're born if
you're born six eight or whatever yeah I
pay more for clothes really well I also
have to get like special jeans and stuff
because I'm not like huge and Tall I'm
just tall we're really attacking
everybody in this area right we're going
after babies we're going after the big
and tall uh-huh
man we'll be a big shoes definitely call
us more it's more materials more
material yeah make sure they're also
harder to find like thankfully I found a
few places around the city that are just
life savers yeah
um what what size shoe uh 14 and a half
wow that's a hard size too at that point
did they even go halves sometimes but
not really you got to go one way or the
other but I wear a lot of boots which
helps boots out yeah what are you I'm
13. wow that's a tiny little baby foot
you got there that's a hoof 89 and a
half
dude wow that was really cute the way
you just did that yeah twirling them
around that was really oh dude feet are
adorable doing a 14.
13. big feet in here Jesus Christ man I
gotta say mine
I'm 11. I'm 11. but my dad eight size
eight shoe huge dong so that is a myth
yeah for sure when was the last time you
saw your dad's Dawn 1984. no no it was a
Tuesday at the wedding he got really
drunk it was already Tuesday yeah no I
think I still have the newspaper
clipping but no yeah it was probably I
don't know 89. oh well that's so no you
remember we might be skewed yeah exactly
you were tiny dude I was Tiny yeah but
he would sleep nude and it would just
really
flop and flip all over the bed nice yeah
is it big to you because you were little
that's the question that's how you do it
you become a legend you're a kid just
show him your dick once when he's like
three yeah and no matter how big or
small the kid's gonna be like my dad's
got a nice hog exactly that's how you do
it yeah yeah let the the lore build
Services has entered the chat
let's just get that dick nice and hard
yeah show it to your kid just once I'd
be like whoa but wait did you you guys
didn't sword fight with the dad
together no started to suck
it was tough uh I never won once uh so
yeah you sort of fighted with your dad
beat my brother my dad you know all in
the bowl oh pissing across extreme yes
okay yes I've done that with my brother
all right there you go yeah I think we
called that uh yeah Crossing stream what
was it called cross on the street
because it was a Ghostbusters joke you
know don't cross the streams no he ever
every kid did that together okay sword
fighting has to do with touching penises
yeah yeah I was making yeah oh we didn't
do that okay they were limp
we intertwined them yeah all right then
there's docking you ever heard of that
oh yeah what is that again I'll bring it
up pull it up put your penis in the
other person's penis that sounds
horrible I mean how does your dick hold
that [ __ ] oh it's not it's a foreskin
thing oh it's foreign all right well you
wouldn't have to worry about that
that's good
also circed are you sure oh yeah just so
late yeah
I assume we all are
yeah oh damn okay here we do any docking
whip it out
I'm gonna surf people say it's
mutilation but I'm gonna do it too ah
the photos just came up [ __ ] me yeah I
don't like ooh I don't like that
your circle when you have a kid you'll
sir it's not helping the NOG yo what if
it's a girl will you sir yes yeah get
that [ __ ] out of there
who needs it
um no but my friend is 34 he got circed
at 31 because he kept getting uh
oh my God that's terrible I know so
isn't that like aren't you in the
hospital or something for that yeah I
mean you had to get surgery right he
said it was a nightmare but he's like
I'll definitely do it to my kid
yeah I mean a barista I remember
geraldo's joke about how he's like I
don't even know what you were to a brist
I just wore a tie with the end snipped
off
that's a great that's a great jokey joke
I love jokes like that that and clean
dude uh yeah brisses were so weird I
remember like you know you have bagels
and you have like Whitefish salad and
some someone's dick gets snipped wow no
weenies it's just weird to be like what
are we catering is it a wedding slightly
different yeah yeah separation yeah man
just that first time you celebrate with
cigar ah it really is that it's the same
thing damn
oh
what a weird gig is it
you're next pull it out
what what a weird you're a child you
just get your you don't know what's
going on you just start crying yeah you
just see a guy with a giant beard and a
knife and you're like what the [ __ ] you
know where they should do it is on
planes the kid's gonna cry anyway yeah
you knock it out
hey folks this show is sponsored by
better help when you're on top of the
world you can do great things but if
life gets you bogged down and you can't
do anything you feel overwhelmed work
with a therapist makes you more prepared
to take on everything life throws at you
we love therapy we're in therapy highly
recommended get the garbage out it's
building up in your head you can't
Fester everybody's festered about
something I don't care who you are Kanye
or anybody else better help us
convenient flexible affordable entirely
online fill out a brief questionnaire
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge easy peasy tell them
how to do it if you want to live a more
empowered life Kanye therapists can get
you there visit betterhelp.com drunk
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash drunk
yes all right drunk Factor okay wait are
we starting now
start off 2023 with your own personal
chef Factor shops preps was that okay
let me redo that my eyes are [ __ ]
dumb start off 2023 with your own
personal chef Factor shops preps cooks
and deliveries to your door so you can
enjoy Chef crafted dietitian approved
minus the hassle these fresh never
frozen meals are delicious and
nutritious we love these guys they're
Chef's Choice options always taste great
they're simple like Kanye and with
calorie smart and keto options facto
meals are perfectly portioned to keep
you on track with your goals Factor now
offers over 34 meals per week and over
three dozen add-on options each factor
meal arrives pre-prepared by their team
of chefs ready to heat and eat in just
two minutes tell them how Mark go to
factor75.com
drunk60 use code drunk 60 to get 60 off
your your first box that's drunk 60 at
go dot
factor75.com
drunk60 to get 60 off your first box get
on it
oh
hey you probably think you spend around
eighty dollars a month on subscriptions
when the actual toters closer to 200
most Americans do you could be wasting
hundreds of dollars each month on
subscriptions you don't even know about
that's why we love rocket money formerly
known as true bill rocket money shows
all your subscriptions in one place even
the ones you didn't know you were paying
for and cancels whatever ones you don't
want you may even find out you've been
double charged for a subscription it
happens to cancel a subscription just
press cancel and Rocket money takes care
of the rest easy
get rid of useless subscriptions with
rocket money now go to rocketmoney.com
drunk seriously it could save you
hundreds per year that's rocketmoney.com
drunk cancel your unnecessary
subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com drunk
no drink liquid IV folks feel like your
best self in 2023 with liquid IV in just
one stick you get five essential
vitamins two times faster hydration than
water alone I like what's your favorite
flavor Mark I like pina colada oh yeah I
like the lemon lime use it first thing
in the morning before a workout when you
feel run down after a long night we've
had a few of those fart like Marcus did
and use it on Long flights uh I use it
uh after charity gigs where I get [ __ ]
faced free from gluten dairy and soy
liquid IV complains complaints I
complain liquid IV contains three time
the electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks it uses cellular transport
technology designed to enhance rapid
absorption of water and other key
ingredients into the bloodstream Mark
tell them how good grab your liquid IV
in bulk nationwide at Costco or you can
get 20 off when you go to liquid
iv.com and use promo code drunk at
checkout that's 20 off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code drunk at liquid
iv.com get hydrated no
what's that you're gonna have a kid one
day am I you are how do you know he's
Baron wait is that the man thing no it's
women what is men
yeah there you go it's Daryl Crow
um will you
um have him that didn't impress me much
[Laughter]
child will you have him yep yeah yeah
just so it looks like your dick I just
want Bagels
I just want to have a good to go to do
that without it yeah that's the point
now here's the question and this is
where we get weird
is a pedophile enjoying a bris or hating
a bris
at the first glance you're like hey baby
dick this is great but is he like ah
you're you're hurting the dick the thing
I love I think it's like a movie where
you love the first half
[Laughter]
yeah
I gotcha second half kind of goes off
the rails a little too violent it's like
the opposite of Saving Private Ryan like
wow right yeah I like the storm on the
beach but uh yeah okay interesting
you're probably right a bris you leave
early yeah
what are we drinking by the way I see
you're like laboring over there this is
an intensive I was waiting for you guys
to kind of get down the NOG a little bit
making a custom tail there's gonna be a
switch up from that a little bit not
gonna be as sweet with a little
sweetness
it's Bodega cat Gold Rush Oh a gold rush
I don't even know I've heard of this I
don't know so Gold Rush is really simple
it's
um it was basically like
um a flip on a riff on the bee's knees
um and what was that again good band gin
honey and lemon so this is going to be
Rye honey syrup and lemon and a little
bit of like nuttiness to it it was some
Disaronno and a little cinnamon oh
disarono
kind of sexy Chris Imperioli no that was
Michael no he did 1809 I think oh he did
the tequila yeah
I don't know yeah it was like a hot
woman wasn't it um it was a woman there
was also this Suave like uh like Spanish
bartender who did a lot of Those ads at
first is that are those uh Fireball
shots I guess
I [ __ ] hate Fireball I do too it's so
not my thing it's lady Yeager that's
good lager yeah by the way hot Doug key
over here oh wow you're right no key is
kind of hot yeah kind of just to add
your camera this is it I guess it was
just a hot bartender you're right 1809
was Imperioli
disaronno's yeah but she's getting like
moist you see her take that wig oh yeah
put a towel down yeah this is what I
mean oh wait a minute
whoa she's anemic
gotta eat ice that's what the name of
people do but you know the uh most
interesting man in the world Jewish oh
is it yeah not a Mexican
finally we're taking their jobs
they are replacing them they are
replacing them yes yes
this is great not bad right now a little
lighter than I guess the heavy nog but I
think that's a welcome change yeah this
is great if I walk into a bar I go give
me a gold rush fatty you'll probably be
able to get in most bars I've been
ordering paper planes at bars they can
all make them yeah yeah
it's Gotta really I'm happy with how
popular it's been getting recently like
everyone's everyone's really into Paper
Planes which is nice because it was it
used to be pretty hard to find like the
Amaro no nino anywhere it's expensive I
didn't know how expensive Amaro Nino
yeah Mar is pretty expensive we only
need a little bit about every time so
like you can go you can also sell out
like other Amari
um or like if you need like Montenegro
in a pinch or whatever it's so good I
don't see this upwards even though you
know which is a little cheaper it comes
in larger bottles okay so there's a lot
of like little substitutes you can get
when like a few people have asked me uh
like a few of our viewers have asked me
like where to get that stuff like up in
Canada and everything oh yeah they don't
know a good cocktail up there
liquor stores are just it's harder
because they're all like Imports right
right right it's so it's such a good
drink I've been making it at home I
ordered it at the bar last night we were
pounding them it's so satisfying it's
just nice refreshing and but it's still
bourbon so it's yes it'll warm you up
even a little bit I think we started a
movement I was at a party once and I was
at a bar and it was open bar and I said
give me a paper plane and somebody goes
what's that then she had one and I had
like 18 guys drinking Paper Planes yeah
they're big they're like it's it's
entered my top five cocktails well done
beer juice somebody uh so apparently
like the well the only people in New
York who like watch our show all come to
my club yeah that's fun the other day
somebody asked if they could have a
paper plane from the beard you whoa
it's a club though so I don't have like
anything to make it with I made
something similar but all right yeah
what do you make if you don't have those
ingredients I mean I made like a like a
bourbon aperol with like sweetened up a
little bit uh and with like some Saint
Germain or something like that like
stuff stuff that I had on hand like it's
like it's just like an owns Club you
know we don't have any like yeah
it must be laid over there it's
literally only uh like younger uh like
dudes who uh actually know about us at
all oh okay is our is our fan base very
dude heavy oh yeah well we're drinking
how do we get how do we get how do we
get more women on board yeah and hit
that femur what shirts off yeah we'll
snip the dick put on the patreon yeah
all right maybe we need more female
guests well this will help this story
speaking of uh Amari El Nino Stoudemire
you watching The Shack doc I haven't
seen it is it good I love you're so in
the sports dog I love it Sports backed
organ you in a bathroom yeah well I like
the story I like the personalities more
than just the running up and down the
court you know I want to get behind the
player that's why I like comedy because
you get to learn about the guy or UFC
you get to know about that this guy grew
up on a farm and he used to beat up his
uh his dad or whatever I like that part
so the check doc I didn't know he was a
pill head I didn't know he was shooting
himself with novocaine to get back into
the game I didn't know how bad he was
hurting I mean he goes all in
he's the best he's great he's a great
guy you just took every video of him
just he'll be in a store and he just
like buys a kid yes there's a great
segment where he like would tell the kid
you never let a stranger buy something
for you unless it's Shaq yeah yeah oh
the bike he bought a bike I love him
dude he's a sweet guy he's a cop his dad
was uh the general military guy yeah the
general uh something Harrison right yes
Sergeant Harrison yeah that would dude
he was such a great player people he's
so underrated because his window wasn't
as long as some of the other guys but
right at his Peak I've never seen him
more Unstoppable no dude freight train
oh he was awesome they talk about the
Kobe beef him and Kobe you know they
were like brothers and then they got
into it and said I know you never know
when your boy's gonna be gone you know
yeah you ever hear Kobe tell that story
about Shaq he was like how come you
don't work on your free throws he's like
you we would have 14 championships if
you could just work on your free throws
he's like I'm good with making 40 yeah
he always would say I make him when they
account and if you look at the numbers
it wasn't true it's like a funny thing
like I'm making when they count yeah he
didn't try he wouldn't he wouldn't go to
training he wouldn't go to practice he
just must be hard though if you're that
big it must hurt your [ __ ] body yeah
he was in pain all the time Kobe was a
psycho I mean like in as you know as a
player that's what you want a guy who
just is like a psychotic trainer and
yeah hear that story in the USA doc
where he's like everyone comes back from
a night out and look for him and he's
already training yeah he's already got
ice packs on his knees from like waking
up at three he would just train like a
crazy dude I mean he was like I gotta be
that much better it's inspiring man
crazy they go in the Penny Hardaway they
hit all the big ones I gotta watch it I
love Shaq oh yeah HBO
HBO's got some stuff that's great yeah
it's like a five-parter I just finished
Larry Sanders I've watched it so many
times yeah so good I've watched it top
to bottom so it's such a good show hey
now what are your Peak moments the
episode where Hank takes over the show
oh my God is sick and he becomes a
monster I love that he's like one good
shed and he turns into a piece of [ __ ]
yes I love dude there's an episode where
Alec Baldwin uh he finds out he [ __ ]
his ex-wife and he's a guest on the show
and he he he has to walk offset he says
to the producer you know uh ripped torn
he goes uh all I can do is picture him
[ __ ] my ex-wife and and she's on top
and he goes lazy bastard
so many good jokes I know Jeffrey
tambor's unreal on that show he is a
beast so funny that was the weed whacker
what was it that he was selling oh the
garden the garden with the pilot is it
really that's the [ __ ] pilot wow the
whole scene with the woman was she says
uh that producer they're trying to get
him do on-air ads and and she goes he
goes you know if you were a woman I'd
take you outside she goes if you a woman
if you were a man [ __ ] I [ __ ] it up if
you were a man I would take your
attention because if you were a man I'd
do it any any Trash there she trashes
them and then she it just cut to him
with a black eye it was a great cutaway
he's just lying to the to the purse to
the uh makeup person he goes yeah I fell
down the stairs
so cool not to get all schmaltzy but
Larry Sanders was being shot at the same
time Seinfeld was being shot both Comics
came up together TV shows at the same
time so they would get lunch you know
and hang out after just him and Han
about Showbiz and what how hard it is to
run a show and all that how cool is that
two of your two bus buds just show at
the same time so cool pretty crazy and
they're both two of the best shows ever
made Larry Sanders is under appreciated
oh yeah it's a great show great show
last season [ __ ] I know I gotta re-watch
it oh dude HBO's got but they're just
getting rid of [ __ ] on HBO do you see
this well they're taking it off they're
just taking not that but like it shows
like Westworld oh they go which I didn't
watch but they just get rid of them and
they're like they're fans of that show
that's that's gonna suck I wonder why
they do that just keep it up I'm
streaming yeah it's pretty that must
suck though if you're on that show and
you're like yeah how do I watch and
you're like nowhere right well you can
watch it on oh never mind got it
oh easy easy
uh but when did you get nervous about
this well he's here if he wasn't here I
could really uh spell it out I'm joking
but I'll mark on every podcast I got
this great hookup
and I got him in my good friend you
could go to his apartment he's located
at
remember the old days you had to go on
the roof and like steal cable like it
was hard to still get the roof to go on
ah yeah we had to go up there clean the
gutter then you do a little finagling
those are different times so you get a
little Playboy channel action oh yeah I
remember like there was a woman remember
robin bird or New York Channel 35. her
tits were just out
it was a big deal that you would just
see a woman's tits out on TV what yeah
it was like Elvira no no they were
actual porn what wait what wasn't porn
it was just a nude woman she wasn't like
[ __ ] no she's not the way you spell
it you ever seen those uh an actual bird
came off huh there we go well
double-breasted all right right have you
ever seen those uh Japanese porns where
it's a lady delivering the news at a
desk and they two guys just stand on top
of the desk and jizz on her no oh I'll
send you a link geez I would watch more
MSNBC if they did that
the sea has come I'm like man Ari
Melbourne's gotten really bad I have
Matt out thank God she's wearing glasses
this is not a good example she used to
do interviews nude and you can put it in
on your cable box really yeah and in
between there were like ads for escorts
and stuff
New York was a CD player oh she's pretty
that's kind of hot
not so fast
all right maybe not but I'm gonna do it
but this is what it looked like this is
incredible
this is on regular TV just flip around
past channel 12. on your on your basic
35 yeah channel 35 it's on your basic
cable package what the hell
and these people would get nude
I don't get why this was legal
we
just kind of went with it
in a while
and then she would take these strippers
and interview them oh fun
boy New York was fun
New York's kind of getting fun again
though you think I think so is that late
last night and there were a lot of
weirdos out and I was kind of like this
is where this is where it's at all right
I get worried when I see bars going away
like old bars you know like Mars Bar
went away and then I think Doc
Holliday's might be gone no that's still
there that's still there all right I
went there the other I went by there the
other day that's a classic classic guy I
went by uh even go to Pete's Tavern on
Irvine oh yeah that's a [ __ ] classic
that you feel like that place just the
wood you're like this place has been
here 100 years or something one of the
best bars in New York easily yeah went
there the other night great night some
guy sitting across to me and he goes we
acted in something together and I was
like definitely not ah dude you don't
want to see my my acting resume it's
pretty light he thought you were
tutorial
after a few whiskey Sam's like oh I was
at Miller's Crossing
underrated movie great movie Cohen
Brothers you know what else is a great
bar about five blocks away from that one
going east not going west is an Old Town
bar oh pull it up 18th Street 18th and
one between Parkway Broadway and pull it
up oh I do know that yeah pull that up
and his ear bar is great on the on the
West Side I've never been to that one oh
That's a classic the ear in right yeah
beautiful yeah that's a beauty pull up
you're in yeah remember Subway in
Subway in ooh that was a dingy one is
that the one that was actually in the
subway it was right next to the subway
there it is ear bar what does that say
1817. they have Burgers there right I
had Burger there once yeah I went there
during the day see there's like a little
thing to tie off uh that it tie ships
with right there so if you go just a few
feet down the road that is where the
water was oh wow and everything else is
built out uh you know by man that's why
I think I went there with Christian
McLaughlin from Comedy Central remember
he's a good dude oh yeah he was a good
guy yeah last one of course we got to
talk about McSorley's McSorley old
school I've been going there once a
month I think that is the oldest bar in
New York City now sawdust on the floor
yeah you guys ever been to uh Rudy's
hello classic do I love Roots hot dogs
yeah yeah you get that's that's when you
you know when you're like hot dog number
three it's time to go home
and which sorely you just order Lighter
dark beer that's it because they have
their own like yeah
they have their own uh like uh beers as
well oh really I mean back in the day
you could get a pint there for like it
would be like six dollars or something
yeah of the Rudy's Red Ale it's still
like four or five bucks and I was at
McSorley's two days ago I look on the
wall there's old newspaper clippings and
everything they're all dingy and yellow
1970 and it's a woman going
that's the photo and it says women are
finally allowed in McSorley's there's a
picture 1970 1970. oh is that this there
you go 1970. what a hilarious idea for a
bar I know no women I know it's like a
men's club I guess yeah it's like every
bar is trying to do the exact opposite
Now ladies drink for free like no you
can't yeah ladies night literally I want
to get drunk and you're like all right
should we let's get some women no yeah
that's just dudes yeah I just want to
get drunk with dudes lock the door man
yes boys night out that was like the old
stories about Phyllis Diller at the for
Irish Club she had to disguise herself
as a man to get in wow I'm sure there's
pictures of it well yeah wouldn't you
well women around it's so weird that was
like the old that was like I think all
those dudes were probably married and
that wasn't their escape I think you're
right like it's weird I had I met this
guy old school guy from Queens Irish guy
uh what do you call that four-leaf
clover tattoo we sat down at a diner he
did this [ __ ] before he ate and I'm
there with may my lady and he goes this
guy's really [ __ ] you around pardon
my language ma'am and I was like whoa I
haven't seen that in years damn it was
fun to see who's talking about you yeah
yeah and she was like I don't care you
know I just drank his jizz 10 minutes
ago but uh but it was cool to see that I
hadn't seen that in years yeah it's kind
of like an old school guy thing totally
old school yeah he was a construction
guy it's weird when dudes it's like you
can't curse around women I've known
people like that like I curse in front
of my mom yeah but that might be not why
they didn't want him there like oh we
can't curse and [ __ ] if they're here
[ __ ] that so they're like weirdly kind
of it's like out of respect maybe we
want to like we wanna we're married we
want to go out and be animals yes and
it's just gonna be around dudes and
maybe they play cards or some [ __ ] it
was just like your Escape right uh
I should have had something oh I got I
got mugged outside of Rudy's really
really I'm not surprised about that
2009. yeah what happened uh went to
Rudy's you know you're [ __ ] up pull up
Rudy's because there's a big pig outside
right yeah don't call her that well I
tried to hook up with the pig that's
when you know you gotta go I was like
because his cheek and whispering in the
ear I think you look great but uh
wet drunk stumbling down 8th Avenue or
Ninth Avenue whatever it is and uh went
to a like an Alcove like a little
apartment with some steps going down I
was like I'm gonna take a little nap
there what yeah you might have invited
this robbery
it's always been my fault and I sat down
and I just kind of put my head against
the wall and just took a little nap and
I woke up and like four guys are going
through my pockets and I was like and
they went he's waking up hit me I went
out again and I woke up phone was Gone
pen was gone while it was gone joke book
was gone keys were gone then you look up
they're like oh no they left behind the
jokes
I wish no that's uh that's that's like
less of a mugging and more of just you
passed out yeah yeah and scavengers
found you yes I got robbed although you
did get hit that sucks I got hit yeah
but at least I went out easy like they
could have just you know roughed me up
but I woke up and you know this is 2009
so it was like pre-iphone pre-smartphone
so you getting back to your house with
zero money and zero credit card it's
damn near impossible so I had to jump
the turn Styles you know run away get on
a train make it home a little easier
though because no one's harassing that's
true but like I know dude it's crazy now
I I was flying back from Lexington
Kentucky and I left my phone in the
guy's car ah my phone is my wallet
connected so I'm like I'm [ __ ] I have
nothing don't have I don't have an ID so
I can't get on the flight so I don't
have I don't have an ID I don't have a
phone to have a ticket and I was like
telling them I was just kind of at the
front desk like what do I do and she was
like there's nothing there's nothing I
was like you know at the end of a
weekend you're just [ __ ] exhausted
you're like I just want to go home yeah
and I was like I'm stuck in Kentucky he
showed up he found it oh which is crazy
because I've lost it all the time and
they never yeah but that one I saved the
day wow I had a similar thing left my
phone in a uber on the way to the
airport get out I'm at the airport and
you go all right
ah my phone and the lady goes oh my God
though the lady at the United was like
call it and I'm like
with what no yeah and then she's like
well well give me your phone number I'll
call it I'm like it's in the back of an
Uber so she calls it 18 times nobody
answers so you're like what do you do so
I just got on the flight and I went to
my gig in Phoenix how were you able to
get on the flight I had my ID
but I'd have the phone yeah see what you
can print out a ticket oh you bought a
new phone in Phoenix no I just I just uh
figured it out like you went a weekend
without a phone I went a weekend without
a phone it was [ __ ] hell it was so
hard yeah why would you not just go to
like an Apple store in Phoenix
[Applause]
you got it back I got it back on back
when I came back to New York
New York damn yeah I don't think I would
I think I would have bought a new phone
I think I would have I would have
buckled it was tough it was like a I was
like a crackhead I was with the trolls
like modern day survivor man yeah I was
using the business center at the Hilton
you know like oh there's my email and oh
let me go on Facebook oh Facebook yeah
you forget how easy it is just push it
up text people I got the opener showing
up the club he's like I've been texting
you I'm like yeah no phone damn that's a
little refreshing every now and then not
when it's worse on you but not for a
whole weekend I slept great yeah right
yeah that is dude I've been using uh
blue light glasses so if I watch a show
or something before bed I you know those
what I'm talking about yeah yeah they
sell them on Amazon stuff you just put
them on and it's like if you watch a
show it's I guess it it's easier on your
eyes yeah so it's easy you know you just
watch a screen look at the screen all
day
you don't wind down no it's bad for
yourself I mean we we I think about
every study is like what's healthy gut
gut health and sleep and we're literally
both Road comic drinkers we're not
healthy people no we just had a pine
eggnog now we're on uh what is it a gold
rush sleep is hard dude it's hard to get
good sleep I know and it's so weird
because you're tired but you just can't
do it I'm like I'm laying there like
waiting for it to click in come on it's
hard to shut off what we do like we got
off stage you're a performer you're like
[ __ ] amped up yeah
I think about like I think more like
less about us how about like being like
a Broadway performer or something that
must be tough as hell because you really
can't like I've gone on stage sick they
can't really do that no you've got to be
at top health yeah and we can go hey I'm
sick and make a joke out of it you know
but they have to just plow through that
is hell they also rehearse like several
times each day so I'm sure they're just
exhausted by the time he gets in bed
yeah like adrenaline or not but they
don't have hecklers
I got drunks yelling out [ __ ] all day
long but it's kind of fun sometimes
sometime but how about the Heckler when
you haven't even gotten to the mic yet
I'm walking out and some guy's like hey
douche I'm like Jesus man like this
that's a horrible precedent for the
whole show like let me get here hey dude
you're gay
[Laughter]
it's [ __ ] insane
the whole thing is amazing it's like an
unwitty Heckle followed by a dude being
like all [ __ ] I'll rape you yeah
dude I gotta pee for you having the
farts
yeah because I look man something about
Chinese food in the winter we've talked
about it Sichuan Chinese I think I
mentioned in the last week
oh man there's a place behind me
sometimes I'll order that fish and chili
sauce not good on the stomach yeah the
next day I'm paying for it I'm trying
not to fart sometimes it gigs where the
crowd is small you know you're doing a
workout show and you're like this is a
small enough show that if I fart they're
gonna know it's me
that's a tough position to be and you
really got to be like let me work on a
do a little Kegel here and make sure I
tighten up yeah it's Eagles it's for
your butt though yeah I don't think so
we should make a beagle
what the hell yeah I don't know what I'm
talking about
but I'm with you and uh there you know
when you hold in farts for a while you
can feel your stomach like it's like
come on man this has got to come out
you're like I know but I'm in a social
situation you know what gives me the
farts the the [ __ ] Delta Lounge I
scarfed down everything in there because
I'm just trying to get all the the free
[ __ ] I go to town that chicken the way
they're just dumping it in I'm like this
can't be healthy chicken no no I ate
soups you know so much of the soup the
tomato basil yes a little chowder I'm
drinking it where are you at with
farting in your seat on the plane well
that's what I'm saying I really try not
to out of respect to the although I was
next to veto so I let It Rip but
normally I try to really uh fart on that
baby maybe that's why he's crying
grab his head hold on
that might kill again it's so fragile
that they guess it hurt him you go to
prison you farted
you farted him to death dude
[Laughter]
I'm in cups what are you in for murder
one yeah how'd you do it
yeah
yeah murder number two oh my god wow
yeah yeah but that United Lounge I'm
like what are you doing to me I'm gonna
get on a six hour flight here and it's
just oh dude I can't I have no willpower
now the road is so unhealthy you stressy
I did this club in Tacoma and they just
it's like doused in candy yeah yeah
drawers got candy I'm like we did three
shows Saturday I'm like you think I have
the willpower being here 10 hours right
you think I'm not just gonna [ __ ]
start chugging Skittles exactly I hate
myself you're gonna lose a foot in that
green room because Comics were indulgent
people and uh it's literally like a
chest of drawers and it's like Snickers
Reese's Skittles M M's I know it's cute
and fun but we're not eight oh dude it's
disgusting you say indulgent I'm like
I'm literally eating I'm chugging
peanuts in one hand and Downing bourbon
in the other and I'm like wow this is
the picture of indulgence yes exactly
it's disgusting your childhood and
adulthood are meeting in one they yeah
it's bad I'm the same way and you gotta
like have some willpower but it ain't
easy because you're there for hours M
M's are so good yeah you know what
Eminem's dude it's like talk about a
[ __ ] home run yeah and whoever came
up with that I'd like to shake his hand
and suck his dick real quick I [ __ ]
nailed it dude it melts in your mouth
do you know why uh M M's were invented
nope oh yes
do you tell us
the hard shell would keep them fresh
because they would you know need to
carry them they would put chocolate bars
in their pockets and they would just
melt it would melt so they said how do
we get them to carry chocolate without
it I could work it any worse right I
know you're ready in the [ __ ]
trenches now you're [ __ ] Hershey's
can't even hold together you're right
you're like hold on German
do my shirt for a while yeah guys see
those war videos like the the Ken burn
[ __ ] where they're they got a bonfire
going they're putting their feet in it
because it's snow they're so cold they
got these dumb little raggedy leather
shoes on ah brutal you see the Peter
Jackson one where he colorized yes oh my
God that was what's it called remember
their names remember they're young
remember yeah I know that was so good
beautiful I saw in the theater because
Chris DiStefano yeah very briefly de
Stefano uh bought tickets and he was uh
it was back when he did the history pod
with the honest so they went and then he
got two extra tickets and he brought me
and uh Ryan Hamilton we also that's
beautiful it was like oh my God it was
like unreal I've never seen like such a
vivid picture of War it was brutal but
man Peter Jackson's pretty damn talented
oh yeah
so good these are 18 19 year old kids I
know dude isn't that [ __ ] crazy and
most of them wanted to sign up they were
just bored wow the British then you
think about what's going on in Russia
right now they're like literally dodging
I mean I don't blame them they're like
half of them are like we don't know why
we're in War I know and then they're
just dodging like if you don't get the
draft notice you don't have to report so
it's just people hiding right and by the
way is that who you want in the war nah
yeah I mean that's like you know
true you think our [ __ ] problems I
know I know I always say that like
there's construction apps are going to
war yeah
I've seen this video
oh man what is this this is a oh small
[ __ ] what is that this guy's getting a
[ __ ] from another Soldier oh dude on
dude yeah and then they drop a [ __ ]
bomb on them and kill them why are we
watching what are you doing to us how
did they find those are Russians it's
okay right now oh sorry
high pressure descent am I Oh I thought
you were I'm like polish okay I guess
there's some Russia in there there it
goes oh that's homophobic
damn wow good aim yeah I just said drone
just with a bomb it's just like let go
oh
two explosions
I stink
I wanted to say you give as much a work
off there dudes exploding while getting
sucked off
it's literally like those sometimes your
crowd will like yell [ __ ] out and you're
like what do you want me to do with that
you ever have that I'm not a [ __ ]
magician dude a guy will say something
horrible you're like all right yeah yeah
I know I had one this weekend he goes
what do you prefer New York the pizza
the [ __ ] and I'm like Jesus Christ man
that's the question I was in both cases
they're they're usually pretty good true
consistent yeah but if you have a really
bad one you're like how did you [ __ ]
this up right it's so simple
you know what I saw the other day in New
York they have those little CBD like
weed Delta eight stores yeah 20 off
student discount and I was just like
we've come a long way yeah with weed no
you got this this is [ __ ] can you
imagine being in a car with a dealer in
like 125th Street in the 90s like I went
to Yale so it's like eighty dollars
you know yeah we have come a long way
with the weed it's healthy now it's like
borderline healthy doctor recommended my
doctor says use it to sleep
yes my parents would find it they would
and she did my mom didn't try hard she
would just take it and like put it in a
closet and I'm like I'm gonna get it
back yeah you're not throwing I mean
flushing it away is almost more
incriminating I guess he's still serving
time for selling weed I don't get it you
gotta let him out that's pretty [ __ ]
up yeah we got grinder out though yeah
she had weed although it's still very
illegal over there
well that was that was hash right there
yeah yeah
that was that was a great trade-off the
immersion of death yeah she's gonna play
this year fantastic he's also going to
play Yeah The Merchant of death he's in
game shape
it was that was worth it what about this
a black lesbian dating app Brittany
grinder all right uh can you believe
he's gonna play it man it's insane yeah
I mean good for her I mean being I
remember when Plaxico burst if you
remember when placed was in prison for
like I mean you're not the same yeah he
shot himself
literally shot himself in the leg he's
pulling out a gun or putting away a gun
in his sweatpants and it went off and
shot himself in the leg he was he was a
[ __ ] New York hero too he was awesome
he was a great player [ __ ] badass
wait I want to go to jail for shooting
himself because you can't carry you yeah
I can't carry New York and also he could
have killed someone else I mean yeah I
think he was in a club in sweatpants or
something yeah why he couldn't like get
it oh damn go chill just for that yeah
sweatpants great way to show the the
package yeah you put on a sweatpant no
undies get the lady going oh yeah dude
and I'm not even well endowed but with
the sweatpant you get some help you do
get help it's like a padded bra yeah
it's nice right it's nice they should
make like a special one like like
Lululemon will come out with it
you know if I was single I would wear
that on dates just like hey hey ladies
yeah just get them get them excited I
think it doesn't look like you're trying
on a date though that's even better wow
he's got a big hug and he doesn't care
whoa doesn't care it goes it does go a
long way I wore pajama pants on a date
once the girl told me on the ditch like
that's pretty hot really yeah I was in
college but yeah
I don't think I could I literally
couldn't find my pants but I was like
[ __ ] I gotta go on a date we should do a
robe app oh I got a badass Smoker's road
we did want to zoom but yeah we should
do that live we got robot
Batman and Robin all right
good idea you got any peeves oh yeah
go ahead okay
this is again relationship [ __ ] love it
my lady and tell me if you guys have
this you're married and you're married
I'm alone you're gay
[Laughter]
um she will talk to me from the other
room on normal volume terrible and I'm
expected I'm like huh I'm in the other
room and she's like so what what did we
say we were gonna get at the store I'm
like I can't hear you and she's like
well come in here I'm like you coming
here you're the one who wants to talk so
now we're fighting Mark's beating off
and noise canceling headphones I can't I
can't get what you're saying
I'm like don't text me I'll ruin the
screen
but yeah yeah so that's a big one she's
I'm like you want to get my attention
you got to come in here or yell yeah I
can't just hear you magically come in
just come in here it's wide open the
yellow is annoying too I yeah the yell
is actually worse loud loud volume maybe
it's because I'm hungover a lot no I'm
with you but loud volume I was in the
store the other day and the guy it was
this morning actually the other day I'm
in the store and this guy comes in and I
have my headphones in and I he's still
too loud he's talking to the cashier
he's just like he's like so what do you
think about and I'm just like Jesus
Christ dude yeah what is that what is
that do you have the iPhone thing or the
earbuds that close it up the sound I
like that that is huge game changer game
changer airpods airpods that's [ __ ] it's
so overpriced but God damn it oh they're
worth it I lost mine I re-bought them in
a second just because they're I need
them because you put in the regular you
know that cord ones you hear everything
you hear so little that sometimes you
risk getting hit by a car I'll take it
but you don't you feel like someone's
like you're walking through I mean I
look both ways but like you a horn can
honk and you might miss it yeah that's
true it's crazy yeah and uh some people
are kind of annoying as they walk around
with them in all all day and like talk
to you with them in and I'm like can you
hear me I don't know what's going on
here even more annoying is the one who
takes the one out like like he's giving
you like he's like impressed me impress
me you might get the second but right
now
you got a window here I hate that guy
that's true is that that's is that a bit
that's not a bit could that be a bit
that could definitely be a bit the one
out and then the two and out dazzle me
yes okay uh Matt you're gonna have to do
some research here but that was my pee
when we were at the old Studio we'll get
out of here you're about a guy talking
about one ear and I said the same thing
I'm gonna feel bad
[ __ ] that happens with Delhi guys all
the time too because especially late at
night they're just like talking to
somebody on the phone yeah like how much
is this and they're just like you're
like is that 17 or can I have it yeah
like and then he just said something
else like in English and I'm like oh
what sorry he goes oh no I'm on the I'm
like how am I supposed to know which one
I know me which one cavities are like
that too they're having a full
conversation with their uncle in the in
the motherland and then you're like hey
is this the turn here the turn they go
dab it down you're like you're talking
about the uncle oh yeah are we facing
Mecca what are we doing here so that's a
tough one I got I do it at other peers
I'm looking uh oh here's a [ __ ] peeve
you ever see like this is my fault for
being on Tick Tock at all and tick
tock's the worst but uh you see these
videos like would you rather stop racism
or be LeBron for one day and then it's
just like a highlight package of LeBron
and I'm like well we know which way
you're like there's not a highlight
package if you're like sanding down to
races you've seen LeBron throw down dunk
I'm like you know what you want yeah I
hate that hate the one where they're
like this was like started on AOL back
in the day the people who were like four
this to 40 people or you're cursed for a
year I'm like [ __ ] you you sorcerer [ __ ]
and then these people and they're like
you know they do that on Instagram now
would be someone like like send this to
people or your dick doesn't work for a
year or something like that
people [ __ ] these people they're praying
on AOC
sandwich my sister's gonna die in a
plane crash or whatever the [ __ ] it is
and that's gonna [ __ ] them up now
they're like if I don't send this I'll
get STD or whatever yeah some guy's
trying to [ __ ] a woman his dick doesn't
work he's like [ __ ] I should have
forwarded that exactly I should have
forwarded that video [ __ ] up yeah
whatever that was called was it a chain
letter was that what it was called yeah
he would send a letter to somebody and
it said if you didn't write back and
send it to someone else you'll have bad
luck yes and it would [ __ ] your head up
imagine doing that with snail mail
that's what it used to be really yeah
yeah it was called The Chain Letter oh
[ __ ] you're right yeah dude I hated dude
snail mail in general is a beef oh I'm
still getting mail I'm like what is this
1992. I know I'm going through [ __ ]
envelopes I'm ripping I'm like what is
this so do you like getting a check
though I love getting it check is nice
it's the only girl
don't you hate getting the bill hey hate
those hate Bill flipped it I'll tell you
I got an Easy Pass bill because I ran a
couple toll bridges thought I would get
away with it but I got the bill and it
has the QR code so I go oh all right now
I can just I'm paid so that's nice so
thank you Easy Pass online if it's an
online thing but I'm like just give me
all my bills on an email yeah I just
want an email but sometimes you get the
online you gotta sign in you got to make
an account you got to start a password
I'm like I'm already out oh dude I'm I'm
so lazy I'm annoyed when I get like a
DocuSign thing for my agent or something
or my lawyer they just send me like a
you gotta I'm like I don't want to do it
same I'm literally and then my ex I try
to give my excuses I'm like please I'm
drunk at a sushi restaurant please don't
make me I'm not gonna hold up yeah well
it's amazing how lazy we get like
sometimes I'm texting I'm like I can't
go to the numbers part that's too much
work just flip from the letters to the
numbers I'm out I'm I'm getting [ __ ]
lazy yes I mean that's why you read
young people's tweets and they're just
like no Capital no punctuation no period
because it just that's how they Tweet
now yeah and I I'm starting to relate
yeah see you later with the c and the U
and I'm like man I'm starting to I mean
like look I hate it's weird that's a
pivot also though when I get like really
bad grammar I am a little annoyed yeah
I'm like phoned it in with someone else
give me your [ __ ] periods here yeah
we're writers yeah you give me a there
there it's with the I.E they [ __ ] that
up oh yeah there's some judgment going
around when you don't know your theirs
or you're yours I think less of you I
think less of you for sure one of my
friends I'm not gonna say who we all
know him he wrote uh
uh where's our car but he wrote where's
our car a-r-e and I was like where's our
car oh boy you're an idiot
maybe dyslexic
if you're dyslexic I'll give you a pass
that is an actual thing but like it
wasn't Hanley it wasn't Hanley yeah it
was a difference just a dumb guy it was
a guy you're always like is this guy
dumb and then he sent that I was like
there it is he's dumb all right it's fun
to get the confirmation yes when you're
on the fence about how if someone's dumb
right and then you find out you're like
yeah he's dumb if I get it will you tell
me
that's not nice this is a mean game yeah
this reveals a lot about you so Monica
well you know women look at that [ __ ]
too what I've heard you know my lady has
all her little hens over and they start
cackling and she's like they're like
this guy tweeted it or DM me or messaged
me and he had all these misspellings it
was such a turn off I didn't call him
again or something like that he wrote
suck my dick with no exclamation point
yeah
yeah that's a good at least they're
offended over that maybe they Factor it
in that's nice I guess so I mean they're
thinking about having a kid with this
guy they're like I gotta have a kid with
a standpoint exactly
I saw a good response to uh an
unwarranted dick pic being sent to you
yeah uh you write back you say the group
chat rated this two out of ten uh I've
got that I've gotten that response
before
[Applause]
that's a funny [ __ ] response yeah
that's good wait she wrote that I'll
write that back oh that's funny because
that's funny that's great yeah oh yeah
the ladies talk here's a theory men talk
about who they [ __ ] and women talk
about how the sex was I don't feel like
like if you get laid I'm not like what
moves did you do how did she did she do
that we just go did you [ __ ] her how was
it awesome all right women go how is the
[ __ ] that's interesting like I feel
like we get the rep as being as guys we
get the rep as being the like talking
about sex but we're so in and out with
it it's really really like got laid last
night cool yeah seal the deal maybe
maybe they'll ask for a pick yeah yeah
but then all you get is a nice and it's
over yes but they'll go all in like a
full Faulkner yeah it's quite literally
in a Buckner
he's like there's a pun on the table and
Mark has an egg
waiting for it yeah
um
so my you gotta oh you got another one
oh I had here's a wreck okay Nostalgia
wow it's very popular very popular but
like dude you ever just go on YouTube
and look up [ __ ] you watched as a kid oh
yeah I was like holy [ __ ] I forgot about
guts on Nickelodeon oh God legend of the
Hidden Temple yes remember that [ __ ]
guts
I started watching I was like this is a
good show well we were the first
generation I think where kids really got
some entertainment oh yeah because
before it was like all right you got
Sesame Street then you got to grow up
that doesn't mean street is [ __ ]
great though it's great but that's for
like a three-year-old we had [ __ ] for
like a 12 year old this is the first
look at this dude this looks like so
much fun though and have you got on this
show I mean you were the king of middle
school yeah but you better [ __ ]
listen you know there'd be a little you
ever see the the big talking uh the
temple yes you'd be like uh in 1942 you
know and and then the other nerds had to
really pay attention right right and
move down those steps how about when the
guys grab the kids when they're going
through the temple they would lose I
don't remember that you think anyone you
think it could ever get abducted by that
guy
grabbing
he just grabs you and never comes back
like where's our son did that guy sign a
form please tell me sign it for him
Legends is the Hidden Temple last round
where they're going through the thing
do you think there's more abductions now
or there's more abductions in the 50s
because in the 50s
you could do it easier but it felt more
frowned upon whereas now it's harder to
do it with the cameras and everything
but but it's probably easier to like
track kids online and stuff like that
that's why you have to like teach your
kid like you know Online safety and [ __ ]
don't like just put your location
wherever you are all the time I hear
about it all day long abduction
abduction watch out but I feel like I
never heard about as a kid
but it was easier then Peter's got a
great bit about uh the have you heard
his bit about uh The Face on the Milk
bottle the kid in the milk bottle he's
like he's like you know the kid's dead
oh he's like he's like that kid's
expired like this milk
and they did they were like he's on a
milk bottle yeah that was it that's all
he had for you yeah this is so this is
they're running through this Temple
oh he's looking for the buzzer
some dude in like a [ __ ] uh in some
furry outfit just comes out of nowhere
and just like captures you you don't
remember this oh no
oh he's got to build a uh some kind of a
statue here none of you remember that
[ __ ] am I making this up no you're
probably right
this drink [ __ ] rules yeah Gold Rush
yeah check it out
okay kids going down a lot
some kind of there we go shoot an
elevator and that is slow 50 seconds
yeah that was it's the 90s yeah I think
so yeah different times
[Laughter]
that could have been a fire pole they
didn't need to do that weird elevator I
think they had those sometimes
okay my up the mine Chef this is quality
this is hilarious though they just do
I mean I was on my feet like come on
Billy you've got this yeah this reminds
me like Saturday or Sunday mornings with
like a bowl a giant bowl of cereal yeah
Cheerios
Reese's peanut butter oh those are good
those are so decadent that's a hard way
to start the day even as a kid you know
what started all this off was uh double
dare yeah double day was [ __ ] good
was that black Summers or something yes
yes that was great I think it was
comedian was that was that where you got
slime yeah holy [ __ ] Nostalgia nostalgic
spawned oh yeah there it is Double Dare
that was a big one look how 90s it is
with the graphics this guy [ __ ] for
sure oh he showed up to the bar in that
pink Blazer and you know the ladies oh
he's locked you were so nice to my son
are you a single mother
you want to get slimed
man this is a good app yeah we got some
zingers this up baby I'll tell you I
watched the Cheryl Crow dock on the
flight home from San Francisco I cried
like a baby why well she went through
hell to get there she's like a young
Canadian lady she got screwed over in
the business the harassment she got
breast cancer it's crazy yeah Lance
Armstrong Dana Lance Armstrong during
the Scandal they were together she's
like God I finally find a guy to meet
and this [ __ ] goes down all right
uh yeah they broke up damn
yeah that's Armstrong that guy's I kind
of want him on the Pod oh he's awesome
he's kind of he's kind of a badass dude
I knew he cheated but he's still [ __ ]
he's still a badass but in the words of
Bill Burr I wrote it up guy but you're
rotted up guy like yeah it's still a win
he was his doc on uh ESPN was incredible
killer that was a great 30 for 30. yes
where he's just like you get him man I
mean it's like he was a competitor he
was a psycho yeah I know he cheated but
he was the best he was the best and when
did you give a [ __ ] about cycling before
him oh it's like Michael Phelps yes did
you care about swimming nope nope he
made a scare yeah a lot of women
swimming before that yeah but yeah it's
true you're right he put it on the map
and uh he had the arm the berries
remember the bracelet yeah Live Strong
that was huge yeah he also had the
Cochran lift song put on your car well
he also had ball cancer yeah so the
first time I heard the joke he must have
[ __ ] on her tits I think I I moved
away I had to like I had to go to the
mountains and think about how great I
love that joke yeah because she got the
bread I mean it's too good he uh he
[ __ ] he [ __ ] rules that's so scary
do you see that cycling at like a fast
pace oh scary that [ __ ] is they're
dropping like flies so [ __ ] fast
sharp turns I'm like that's and it's
muddy [ __ ] it might be scarier than not
it's not scary than like Formula One no
no but it's like it's right there oh
yeah it's crazy the road is like this
thin and they're all like elbowing each
other and then they fall and eight other
guys fall that's crazy we need a good
cycling comedy yes get Will Ferrell dude
just do Talladega Nights but cycling
menstrual cycle
it would be like a Bridesmaids
what a surprise we don't have more
female viewers right now yeah we're
really [ __ ] we're really bombing here
this is really a [ __ ] boy why don't
we have more female viewers uh a room of
six dudes
why don't more women like us making uh
puns about their [ __ ] what the hell
we have the time 1968 uh McSorley's over
here yeah yeah a woman comes in we're
like get out this is a boys club
we need to wait two more years Fortune
phoebster Natasha Dina oh yeah Rosebud
we've got some good original
we gotta get Rachel back rules killer uh
dude uh yeah the Natasha app just came
out that was a great app that was a
fantastic
oh great laugh
yeah she's like an old-timey Soul yeah I
like old souls man Good Egg yeah um yeah
a lot of good messages about that love
the app love the other yeah men and
women she also has like really cool
style she came in that crazy green dress
always just awesome always fun outside
Style's fun yeah it's it's cool because
not everyone gives a [ __ ] it's cool to
give a [ __ ] yeah especially if you have
your like your own thing where you like
take the time to like always do that
because I wear the same three things and
they're all black so it's tough for a
guy because a guy can be like wow that's
fun or like what the hell come on I mean
look growing up I thought like I was
like man suit comic that's cool but I'm
like I don't care enough to be but then
I see a guy go up in a suit like you see
like a Tom pop or something yeah no man
he looks real good I know what do you
think about that well I think it's got
to be you it's just not you it's not me
yeah so like remember Louie tried to do
a suit for 10 minutes and it just didn't
work but but then he kind of aged into
the suit I guess 2000 he did that later
special in the suit and I thought he
looked good yeah but he's already back
to black shirt Yeah well yeah maybe it
was him at that moment right because
like I remember we were talking about
that half hour special he's in a suit
and yeah it didn't look right no but
then when he got older I thought it
looked kind of when you're older you
kind of age into a suit I think as a guy
yeah it is weird for a young dude to be
in a suit it looks like you're trying a
little hard I think well mullaney pulls
it off he's but he's he's such an old
soul he's right he's rare
um and also he's playing in like Radio
City that's true like there's a lot of
factors here with Mulaney where it's
like massive venue
fits the style but then I've talked to
people who say like you know I'd love to
see him in like a [ __ ] just a regular
jacket or something that'd be nice
because maybe we're gonna look dumb as
[ __ ] in like 20 years in these bomber
jackets how much we're like leather
jackets are like what's with these
bombers oh Seinfeld already he made fun
of me he's like you guys are all wearing
this jacket don't you realize you're all
wearing this and I'm like well you're
wearing a [ __ ] sport coat yeah we
have Nike Shox yeah exactly so like
what's the difference there's a
different updated jacket yeah we all
look dumb yeah exactly well like just
get a [ __ ] jacket that fits and
you're fine Comics have this huge fear
of standing we want to blend in because
you know every combo sounds good it is
good but we have that fear of every
comic going what the [ __ ] is this guy
wearing you know you walk into the room
and you're like ah yeah but if you back
it up who gives a [ __ ] with you it's
true you gotta get over that it looks
[ __ ] ridiculous and delirious but
he's got a great hack so who gives a
[ __ ] and he's cool as [ __ ] the same with
Chris Rock he wore that crazy leather
[ __ ] and it worked yeah cause he owned
it it looks weird now it does it's a
baggy leather jacket then he wore a red
suit that maroon uh oh that looked
pretty cool that wasn't bad Never Scared
Ron I thought he looked kind of badass
good because it can it places you in
that era when you look back at for sure
you're like this is this one this is
that you know you know special yeah and
it's a great [ __ ] special I'm just
saying like like the Jim Carrey shoulder
pad suit you know the mustard yellow one
yeah that's what I'm talking about oh
yeah that was ridiculous yeah the Clint
Eastwood faces what if we're gonna talk
about Comics dressing wildly on stage
Kat Williams I mean but he's a wild guy
so I think he's if he were if he wore a
next Pilgrim outfit yeah exactly
he would not look I want Williams on
this podcast
can we roll that into the World Cat
Williams can we tag him folks we we
might be drunk I think he'd be a great
guest I think he's funny as [ __ ] he's
hilarious would he you think he would
come on I think he would come on you
just got to get it out to him I just I
don't know if I like how long he can
just sit for wild maintenance
he's rambunctious we need to put a GoPro
on him like he'll just be running down
the street yeah I can keep getting real
amped up and walking and talking pacing
down the hall so much energy on stage
that's what he's saying like he's
sprinting across the stage constantly
the ask this week was that Matt Peters
our producer with a great call uh saw
Simon Rex a podcast favorite was in town
so I did message him and ask him to come
on and he agreed forgetting he just had
back surgery
so he's recovering right now and I was
like dude don't you're on drugs and
you're [ __ ] you have spinal surgery
and he goes you're right that's how much
you want
speedy recovery Simon Rex see his movie
Red Rocket uh he's on Pete Davidson's
new show coming out oh nice a lot of
guys on that yeah and uh we love Simon
man that's good that's all we're saying
here we love you son if you haven't
heard of the other app with Simon it's
one of us
killer app feel better feel better Simon
uh I got that back blown out how's he
gonna get are you gonna get nominated
for something you think this year
oh yeah maybe you could get nominated
right oh I don't I don't know that was
last year that came out last year I saw
the whale over the weekend what do you
think excellent really yeah it looks
like an exercise in torture it is so
exercise
I heard it was uh mid I heard that's how
he walks
he Waddles yeah I heard it was just like
so so it's like a real like sad off yeah
yeah it is they show his body right wow
was it hard sitting there with an
erection
was is it better than the wrestler no no
aaronovsky's a great director yeah yeah
he's amazing movies [ __ ] dude seeing
him in the theater get to the [ __ ]
theater
oh no Angelica good for you classic I
love that you hear the subway every 20
minutes yeah right here you think it's
part of the movie yeah it's an iMac yeah
like oh yeah it's an indie film it's
probably not how about this realization
Angelica is on Houston Angelica Houston
come on that's something blew my mind
all right I thought of that while high
once yeah
Houston she was [ __ ] she was sexy I
got a wreck for you Angelica Houston
movie The grifters I don't know Steven
freers directed it it's uh youngjan
Cusack youngannette Benning uh with uh
full frontal really cans cans it's a
good movie yeah really dark movie I've
never heard of it of course Stacy
produced it I didn't know what
what four years I don't know for years
oh he did High Fidelity man oh okay it
began
oh wow she was a lady
[Music]
it leads to betrayal you're working so
manually don't tell me you're not
because I wrote the book what do you
sell anyway self-confidence you're not
skimming this female
oh well you know
clip the buck here in the butt there
really good movie oh man what who wrote
the book it's a famous book of is it
John Thompson or something no not Tom
Wolf it's in the good Noir it was it
John Thompson maybe who wrote it not
John Thompson Jim Thompson I mean my
dumbest [ __ ] who wrote it yeah yeah all
right no it's like an old it's like a
cool
it's a really cool movie and dark as
[ __ ] yeah really well made loved her and
witches we were witches oh man it was
like a kids movie but it was super dark
it's an old book is that based on the
what's his name
Matilda author yes I think so there she
is great movie she steals it she rules
she's the head witch but uh David
Nicholson I know it could have been easy
no no imagine that those nights out the
blow and the booze and the just driving
up and down the Hollywood Hills and some
convertible whoa yeah no she's uh
Hollywood royalty man oh yeah John
Houston she was great in uh Life Aquatic
to the wife yeah World Tenenbaums yes
zizo shoots blanks dude uh
her [ __ ] dad directed did he not
direct the Maltese Falcon wait he did
the Searchers no no that was that's a
different Houston
Sam Houston what did he do what did he
direct John Houston Sam Houston's
airport that's the city's name no he did
uh African queen maybe he did a dumb
some Bogart movies oh Maltese fault he
did direct it that was like his big
break yeah treasurer of Sierra Madre
yeah the Misfits but I don't believe
that what do you mean I'll believe it
I thought that was
uh what's his name skeptical Solomon
oh nope wait a minute dude no Maltese
Falcon was a movie that like they didn't
think he had What it Took and it was a
hit that was like the big
he was [ __ ] around too he was in the
tabloids sticking around on her mom oh
really yeah wait what about uh who's who
who's the Searchers uh John Ford
oh that was way off yeah sorry everybody
that's a great [ __ ] movie oh yeah
Spielberg's favorite is his favorite
movie oh yeah dude Spielberg on NPR
Great interview have you seen the
fablemans yet I didn't love it really I
thought it was a little slow damn yeah
and I I it looks great it's well done
the acting's great but it's uh I gotta
see it it never grabs you you know it's
you don't care about anybody you see a
lot of movies what else you see well so
like the shack I saw the Sheryl Crow so
I was on a on a documentary kick the
lady saw whale and thought it was solid
I'm not dying to see it I want to see
that movie tar with Cate Blanchard
that's supposed to be ah we're talking
I'd like to see that she's hot super hot
and great also Babylon looks fun didn't
get like trash Oh did it Damien chazelle
that guy's [ __ ] great the the trailer
Whiplash looks amazing yeah
yeah man
um y'all check it out all right oh yeah
wait we'll be [ __ ] bro hey man it's a
long app we sometimes we [ __ ]
sometimes we just talk people throw this
on the background though who gives a
[ __ ] do you think movies will be okay
you think they'll keep making you know
what bums me about movies that they're
like a lot hinges on the success of
Avatar and I'm like well I don't [ __ ]
like those movies I don't like I don't
like these [ __ ] it is hilarious in every
article is like this is just about uh
like uh cultural appropriation like it's
hilarious that ah it is I know but it's
hilarious it is it is the classic story
of the white dude who becomes one of
them and is the best oh is that right
yeah you know that they took the first
Avatar and then took the official plot
synopsis of Pocahontas it's just changed
the proper nouns yeah the same exactly
yeah yeah no he's always been told a
million [ __ ] times it's a very
unoriginal story and uh I think the
first avatar [ __ ] blew I saw that in
the theater yeah I did too because it
was 3D it was I saw it too and but I'm
left being like I feel nothing I think I
don't know if it was but I think the
social network came out around the same
time I remember being like that's a
[ __ ] movie great movie we've got
writer brain you're not into spectacles
I just don't like good writing dude I
think James Cameron makes some great
[ __ ] movies I love Terminator I love
T2 I love True Lies yeah I just am not
like that into
sci-fi blue [ __ ] it looks like you're
watching a [ __ ] scene in a video game
yeah I'll watch them you know what I do
when I'm playing Halo I skip that horse
[ __ ] cause I want to play I don't give a
[ __ ] about the about the little
in-between scenes I'd like to watch them
[ __ ] can we get an avatar porn they do
yeah oh great yeah hey what color is the
jizz is it also blue
I got questions that'd be a great review
I couldn't I didn't see the Jazz so I
can't I can't oh
[ __ ]
full suck it's almost spent a lot of
money on making this I don't know I
don't like how quickly Salamanca had
this holy
[ __ ] this guy really he really was like
I got this [ __ ] clip ready to go wow
those bookmarks no you know what annoys
me though like there's so many great
movies out like why are we oh why are we
it's like the the
it sucks that it's got to be a movie
like that or a Marvel movie I know
that's like that
movie theaters are depending on to
survive it's a bummer you know it's so
many great well we've dumbed it down you
need big explosions blue people you know
spaceships we can't good dialogue and
all that kind of out people are lazy
because exactly you know that you have
so much access to [ __ ] at home you you
know all these streamers it's
inexpensive too so going to the movies
is expensive but then you look at you
know all the stuff you could watch at
home and you're like well it better be a
reason to get me out and I think that's
where the why the only reason the big
budget movies are are what they're
depending on but like [ __ ] I wish they'd
make like I thought knives out too was
really good everybody's raving about
glass onions yeah people are running out
yes Edward Norton it's cool to see a big
budget movie with a brain yeah yeah it's
good writing Ryan Johnson I mean he's
he's made big budget movies that are
smart I thought Looper was a big budget
oh he's got a great resume he's [ __ ]
great that guy just did uh what what the
[ __ ] oh I gotta listen yeah uh he's
great big fan hold on [ __ ] I had another
thing about him
it's a great movie the last great movie
great like the whole country's talking
about it I'm talking like Pulp fictiony
kind of I don't know if that happens
anymore that's what I'm saying
I don't think the whole country is
United on anything White Lotus I haven't
heard anyone say anything bad about it I
don't like it oh he's the one there you
go but that's a good uh good nominee
because I thought it was great the
second season's fun really do I have to
go back to it the second season is
better than the first you can start with
the second season really yeah it's all
different cast and everything I should
give it a shot yeah it's layered it's
nice very layer good dialogue it makes
you think it has two sides fighting
where you're like well maybe you got a
point there maybe you got a point there
which of the country kind of needs right
now maybe I'll give it a shot you guys
might have just [ __ ] talked me into
it there you go I mean I'm watching Mad
Men I'm going this is good writing this
is man's [ __ ] great and heavy and
smart and it makes you want to drink in
the afternoon that's what we're doing
yeah no Batman is really
top top one of the top shows that we
talk about it so much I know it's just
so good Draper's so hot he's so hot the
the chiseled Jaw so my friend went to
the SNL party last week because the it's
the last one of the year it's like a big
deal he said I don't know if I supposed
to say this but he said the whole party
sucked everybody's a queef now but
showed up not even on the show just
showed up
blacked out sat on I'll be saying this
all right I mean he was there in public
but he was sat on a couch Indian style
and like just
you know live it up we can't do that all
right he didn't do anything bad he was
just trashed you can't we don't want to
say that though about him you know I
think you know people know he drinks but
all right all right we I will say that's
a guess we need on this pot
how do we get him on the Pod one of my
favorite drinking scenes what the [ __ ] I
was looking at Mad Men
[Laughter]
he's supposed to be like our footage guy
he's just watching porn
you're like what chicken run hold on
it's rule 34 embodied um
no that that drinking that was like one
of my favorite drinking scenes or like
barting season General where he helps
the uh older like Mogul make uh
yeah
that's a great [ __ ] scene and he does
it correctly yeah and before that for
that time sure that's the end that's
literally the episode where uh Roger
Sterling does a black face at a party oh
I feel like wow this is they really feel
you back and forth with some of these
characters yeah uh he's a great
character I mean it's a great [ __ ]
that's a great show man how did they try
out to be Don Draper who Sterling oh if
you re-watch it now they do a disclaimer
before
they say uh we don't condone blackface
and it's like I said keep it in the
series otherwise you have to take it out
like I did with her it's so [ __ ]
funny that they have to write that like
anyone's watching like this is still
cool right is this okay to do at a party
yeah uh no they do well they got rid of
the episode of It's Always Sunny right
would they do black and it's one of the
funniest Sunny episodes great up it's a
great it's the way they do the uh Lethal
Weapon oh the yes yeah yes I'm getting
too old for this [ __ ] oh they do it on
Seinfeld Kramer does blackface at one
point the chicken one well no he gets a
really crazy tan and then but that's
what he's waving with the chicken right
the chicken wing I think it's before
that I think it's before that I know
that one but that's Kenny Roasters this
is earlier where he gets a really crazy
he falls asleep in a tanning bed and
he's dating a black girl at the time and
he goes to meet her parents what the
[ __ ] is this they thought he was mocking
them so they kick him out it was funny
it can be funny I know it's offensive
but that doesn't mean it's not funny
luckily that was the only time uh
Michael Richards ever offended a black
person
good point uh
oh you had it you had it no no that's
the n-word rant don't pull that up it'll
get me inspired to start writing there
we go yeah later up maybe oh maybe
you're right maybe it's the chicken one
let's see how he's meeting the family
and she's like what the hell is this
gonna get pulled off YouTube for a
showing this [ __ ] oh it's on YouTube
never mind
that was it
man it's time for there's a couple of
dicey scenes but you know 1993 or
whatever
yeah well you're not gonna even
Seinfeld's like low-key kind of edgy
you're gonna yeah you're gonna funny
David yeah you're gonna walk that line
occasionally you're worried about that
blackface grammar thing but not worried
about like the Avatar porn that I well
that's fake oh that's a cartoon
um yeah I just assume he's gonna believe
the uh you know oh yeah
he's on it
um that would be great if we got pulled
for the black face but not two blue
people [ __ ]
blue face blue face
um
[Music]
that was an epic era of dog [ __ ] music
oh that's a Barbie girl I was going to
that next holy [ __ ] we're in sync
periods another terrible band
thanks a lot folks we'll see it should
we wrap it up on something sure I'm
still proud of menstrual cycle we gotta
get that movie made we had some [ __ ]
Clips in this episode I feel like all
right leave some good I mean look we did
ramble a little but we had some [ __ ]
moments oh yeah no good stuff good up I
felt like the last one I wasn't on my
game great no no this one we were back I
was off
me and salky's talked later he agreed
really yeah damn [ __ ] twisted the
knife Salamanca I mean I had to stop him
for watching porn for one second to talk
to me but yeah we're at the diner he's
just [ __ ] like oh [ __ ] look at that
[ __ ] he's like oh and Harry Met Sally
porn
even worse when Harry met Sully porn
[ __ ] on the plane that just barely
landed
how great is Sully I know they made a
movie about him but that is that guy's a
[ __ ] guy real badass that guy rules
yeah real hero that guy I think about
that all the time on turbulence you're
like man me too does this pilot have
Sully balls or is he a [ __ ]
if if we have to land in the [ __ ]
water can he stick it or yeah talk about
great movies Flight Denzel I always saw
parts of it but I don't know yeah I do
so good John Goodman I remember being
yes yeah there's that great scene where
he apparently something happens with the
plane where it [ __ ] up some with the
malfunction and he lands it and they go
we tested 10 other pilots in a simulator
and nobody could land it like you did
and you were drunk and they go we found
two bottles of vodka in the garbage only
you had access to it and he goes well
it was actually three and they arrest
him because he has to like invert the
plane or something yes the plane goes
upside down it's a whole thing man
Denzel is a [ __ ] it's not a true
story right no I think it is yeah I
think they obviously embellished a lot
like all the flight movies are based on
besides airplane it is weird when you
see someone watching them on a flight
yeah that's true you know what I mean
like you're like is this like the
extension of the prep video right oh the
shaky the shaky plane I I don't like
seeing it on a plane no no I'm thinking
about it Final Destination is one of the
options on United I'm like what are you
doing that's crazy I remember thinking
that movie [ __ ] stunk yeah it's like
putting Schindler's List on an amp track
you know they don't have movies the
premises they cheat way they cheated
death so now death is like pretty pissed
off yeah you [ __ ] dude you [ __ ] you were
supposed to die yeah and now I'm gonna
kill you one by one and we're just
horrible impossible
um death is a [ __ ] kind of a woke
[ __ ] yeah death sucks what a cuck
all right uh do we do it or do we do it
rick
made a few yeah okay okay you do a bit I
don't know what I have oh yeah we gotta
do a bit I don't know if I have any good
bits bro I'm bad at comedy and I got I'm
scraping the barrel here
anything I can't uh I have one I can't
[ __ ] finish all right it's not good
here we go
can I try it please I have some all the
other new shit's just either hidden or
not hitting this is one I can't crack so
I don't know if I ever did this in the
pot but I saw a man on a leash ah wait
what he's in full leather bondage on a
leash getting walked by another man in
the West Village
where else and my friend turns to me and
he goes uh he goes hey it's a little
weird but you know he's just doing his
thing you got to respect it and I was
like do I I accept it I have to respect
the the right like you know like he's
walking by I got to be like yo that's
[ __ ] dope dude like I don't think
that's what Aretha Franklin was singing
about
this is very respectable so I want to do
a thing about how like you know this is
the ankle it's like I can't sometimes
people say homophobic [ __ ] like how do I
explain gay to a kid I'm like pretty
easy this on the other hand
bit more complex yeah if you're a dad
talking to a kid like Daddy why is that
man on a leash well my guess is he was
sexually humiliated at a very young age
and uh well now he likes it and he's
like well why in public well he's what's
known as a submissive uh you know he he
just you know he wants people to know
but what about the guy walking him he's
a Dom he likes to be in control but why
not just walk a dog well anyone could
walk a dog a human that's uh that's real
obedience and power and then I he's like
Daddy why do you know so much about this
and that gets a pretty big Pop I don't
know where the [ __ ] to go right go where
it's like uh because I'm a sick [ __ ] too
I just dress better than these people I
don't know what to say that's not the
bib it needs something sure you know
what I mean it's like right there I like
it maybe something about how you do your
sick [ __ ] behind closed doors yeah with
the shades yeah that's like that that's
why you're on a leash to me like I don't
know like a kid yes there's a lot of
kids on leashes
yeah you want to go you know well it's
something about like how you're like I
think the point in life is like just
also the first thing I know about you
should not be your fetish oh that I
should know what gets you off that's not
your name yeah you know what I'm gonna
do an act out where you you're the dad
and the kid and then the kid like pulls
his lead she's like why do we have this
dad you know that's a good twist at the
end yeah
because I don't trust you also you can
save the dog thing don't mention the dog
thing and then when the kids walking the
dog later be like oh is that your dog
like I'm a dumb you know like the kids
using the lingo right yeah
well that's good I mean it's right there
it's right there [ __ ] I think the kid on
leash is not bad
yeah the turn is that he's on the leash
I thought of that originally I just I'm
like is that
I don't know it's a very New York thing
well you're gonna have to get like full
full like gross with it
like but why am I in a leash dad right
yes yes put your snout back on Timmy and
you keep harping on how weird it is how
weird it is and then so it'll make the
misdirect even harder when the kids on
the leash
yeah
pretty good your Kink is weird if you
can [ __ ] shop for it at Petco
yeah is the guy [ __ ] too like is he
full dog no no okay you see you've seen
that in New York right I've never seen
that on a guy I've seen a kid no I've
seen him like people walk around really
people on leashes Wow have you ever been
to like the uh uh what is the uh East
Folsom Street Fair
it's not fair it's like a huge like uh
like Kink uh convention out on the
street like in um Hell's Kitchen
right right under The High Line so you
see people getting paddled it's like
it's like four square blocks oh wow also
maybe the angle is too like it's weird
to see a fetish
alone like you see furries it's a
convention they're together this is
weird because it's just happening
isolated it's isolated
a furry you know dominator in the wild
yes yes so close all right what do you
got
um all right so uh I was in Spokane
Washington not bragging yeah and there
was a white pride March and I was like
what are you doing there's no black
people here like it's the most pointless
you're you're rebelling against
something that's not even a problem you
know there's no black people to smoke
can it's all a bunch of like blonde
Toothless in Washington yeah yeah meth
guys and I'm like that's like going to
that's like being like we gotta get rid
of these Asians they're like we're at a
community college that's not here they
go to real college
I like the turn is uh I like that it's
like yeah that's funny it's also funny
that you're like yeah you're guess what
everything's a white person march here
right right you're just going to walk
it's a white person Marge yes you don't
need a parade yeah well that was my
other angle is like you could have a
parade we're celebrating wow the
celebration would make more sense than
the actual anger
yeah it's weird it's like uh a white
person that you hear about that all the
time where places are like it's like a
white person Marsh and you're just like
but it's only white people yeah it's
pointless you're it's it's like a dumb
dumb line was it's like having a Weight
Watchers in Somalia it's unnecessary I
want to [ __ ] on Somalia it's in it's
like uh
Spokane Washington yeah you picked the
what it's funny they did a thing and uh
I remember in Whitefish Montana there
was like an anti-ju Marsh I remember
being like Whitefish
that's funny white fish is what you're
doing where's the next [ __ ] uh March
uh smoked salmon Georgia the filter
no but it's like yeah you're right funny
about the uh
it's pointless they're not even here
yeah yeah why are you angry it seems
like you picked the right place to live
exactly exactly that's my point
um so the Asian thing what was the March
about it was just it was like white
pride white pride you know and I'm like
but you did it it's over yeah it's a
waste of time yeah you live in a shitty
City yeah enjoy your wife by the way
that's like no disrespect to Spokane the
downtown's got a few nice Parts but it
is one of the things we were like
the better cities are diverse yes if you
want if you want to have like your white
power thing
just [ __ ] you know yeah yeah
I think the bit there's not much to it
that's the problem I think that's the
bit it's like an Asian at a community
college that's funny it's like you're
like uh yeah I mean this is they're not
even here yeah that's why your tests are
so so bad you know you've known to cheat
off
so that was that so that's kind of
that's one of these bits I tried to blow
out but it's really just like a
two-liner yeah it's done it's done yeah
it's funny so I got another one that I
need your help on but it's quicker okay
NASCAR uh-huh you know it's from
prohibition guys would swoop up their
cars get away from bullies that's how we
got NASCAR huge American sport built
from a criminal activity pretty crazy no
other sport is like that no guy was ever
banging a lady her husband comes home
Cox's a shotgun he runs out the back
door jumps on a bike swims to a lake
triathlon
that's great I didn't do this last week
am I oh I think months ago oh I get well
Triathlon is new but triathlons knew it
was something else that's a great bit it
doesn't kill it does like ah
Triathlon maybe it's too long ago it's
such a long setup maybe there needs to
be jokes in it I don't know say it one
more time
I try to spit out the prohibition thing
quick NASCAR okay NASCAR's for
prohibition criminal activity yeah
criminal actually led to a major
American sport no other sport has an
origin story like that yeah guys banging
a woman husband comes home grabs a
shotgun the guy runs out the back door
jumps on a bike swims through a lake
problem is that's not criminal activity
like turn Styles is jumping up what's
that hurdles oh yeah there's got to be
some criminal activity yeah I wanted
decathlon what's the one where you shoot
a gun and swim
ski and shoot ski and shoot robbing a
liquor store the cops show up right you
shoot your way out then you shoot a duck
uh oh yeah something like uh it's got to
be more like uh what What's a crime
that's fine maybe it'd be funny if it
was like a more white collar crime too
because it's so different if it's like
you know you rip a bunch of people off
you uh you know you do a Ponzi scheme
you blow people off you uh you fled
really quickly in a Lamborghini you go
in circles right you go from The
Hamptons back to your house in New York
what is that formula one yeah okay I
can't I'm not at the right angle that's
not the right angle it's like uh could
we could be you know tour to France yeah
but I do think the triathlon thing is
funny it does it I think it's so long
that and then it's just like Triathlon
people are like ah okay so the first
time you see it coming too it's a crime
uh yeah I need more of a crime
so the first part is this NASCAR we did
it maybe it's like something more
opposing government
ah and that way you make it about like
abortion or something of guns like
embezzling or something money laundering
well you're saying
this is uh
is there something could be the high
jump something could be oh yeah high
jump what's the thing when they were
scaling football with your leftover
boner when you're running away from us
oh God I'm not that well endowed
ha
that's a great punchline though you're
like my dick is so [ __ ] big did I
just pull ball with him I was like yeah
oh yeah
um yeah yeah this one is like it's a
tricky one for sure because it's like
started with a Criminal I think another
problem is people people don't know this
so it's like they're learning something
and then they're exactly exactly because
I didn't know that I'm giving a lot of
information uh it's
there's also a brilliant racist joke
from like the 60s
brilliant it's clever it's really clever
so it's like uh hey you know black
people steal
uh shoot and something else basketball
uh so they're kind of similar I don't
know if it's brilliant well it's pretty
you know steel [ __ ] there's another one
I can't remember what the other one is
something about basketball damn it but
it's not brilliant but it's like oh
that's clever you know boom boom boom
run jumping steel run jump and steal
maybe okay
and shoot
run shoot and steal yeah but but so I
was trying to think of something in that
way not to not that I'm using the racist
joke as my muse
first of all of Mark's jokes had Origins
I'm like Mark there's a joke from the
clan from 1914. just the brilliant ones
it's really good I mean it's cleverness
of these jokes no of course even even
ignorant premises have something
sometimes but so okay your how do you
stop black people jumping on the bed oh
boy
you don't know that one we know it all
right I don't but okay it would work for
Sam too that's true all right do it for
Sam put Velcro on the ceiling all right
all right all right okay the audience is
laughing at home showing to 10 minutes
ago
that motion will stop washing
long end of this episode look at the
witches they they cut out uh this is
worse than your chunk
[Laughter]
what is it uh get us off the air here no
but besides besides starting NASCAR the
prohibition are also led to the rise of
like Al Capone and all those so it's
like the prohibition was also like the
prohibition against weeds so you go into
like a little more historical fact gives
you a little more room to make jokes
yeah I'm just scared by giving I don't
want to do a [ __ ] Ted Talk up here on
uh on prohibition but but that's true it
led to like a lot of organized crime
yeah it started like the American yeah
also started border towns that's how we
got Mexican border towns people just
like I need a drink I'm going to [ __ ]
Tijuana
trying to think about this bit still
yeah something here we just need the
right sport because that the steel thing
over the Border I don't know oh yeah ski
vaulting is the ski one yes it's funny
because that's already a funny thing
bobsledding is funny yeah like if the
sport is funny it might help the bit
like Seinfeld that great bit he's like
Bob's that's the weirdest thing there's
no sled this is Bob you know great bit
of his but uh
still nothing on that basketball black
but all right
uh
I don't know we need the right sport I
hate when there's not a I also thought
something could be funny but maybe
that's why they drove in a circle in
NASCAR as they were hammered you know so
now you could now you could go after
drinking a NASCAR connect those somehow
he was against government you've been
noodling on this for months that's how I
work I feel like if you can't crack this
it can't be cracked no you you you will
I got bits eight years in the making
really oh yeah no we all have I mean
Mark can tell you my white knight bit
took [ __ ] what five years yeah
and it turned out great it was a closer
take long I I almost put in a special
before thing and I was like I'm glad I
didn't yes you got to sit on some [ __ ]
and there's no rush no rush pull this
quote up Einstein I'm not smart I just
sit with problems longer on that one
Einstein Einstein I can't jump on a bed
but I'm pretty cool
he also said creativity is knowing how
to hide your sources oh and he was a
patent player so is that right
brilliant guy
it's not that I'm smart
it's just that I stay with problems
longer there you go you just stay with
bits long time and you eventually get it
it's like my ex-girlfriend
but you say with a bill too you're all
right people don't know you sat with
that bit for four years that's the when
they see the bit they go that's [ __ ]
great this guy's a genius you're like
actually took me 10 years but they don't
know that
my wife she's all right she's all right
she's kind of that point where I'm drunk
Rodney
good teacher really seems to care can I
tell my Jeff Frost story real quick yeah
so uh as you know Caroline's is closing
all right R.I.P to Caroline great Club
New York state did we give him up I
think we did on the last year yeah we we
had great times there I heard they're
moving so there might be another
iteration I hope so yeah it would be an
end of an error so they started in South
Street Seaport I didn't know that and
then they moved to Broadway 40 years ago
started in Chelsea Chelsea it was a
Berlin a cabaret and they had Monday
night comedy night and it did so well
they said let's do Tuesday too and then
it took over the whole thing sorry oh
yeah so um so they're having like some
big guys close it out and so last
weekend was Jeff Ross next weekend is a
tell I don't know when this air is Patel
has done every Christmas Christmas like
so that's what he's doing he's done it
every year since I was in high school I
went to see Ivory no way I have a signed
playbill from Dave Attell from like 2004
are you gonna be in town on the 28th I
won't be unfortunately
Thursday I know I'm flying to Spokane
dude I remember that Playbook you called
him sugar gay and he got bad
he's like what the [ __ ] I'm gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of me I was like sugar gay
put me in a [ __ ] headlock oh yeah he
called me sugar gay they made me suck
his dick dude that sucks get to the
store
I'm gonna keep going with this and then
I'm acting it out
so uh you know tell us going next
weekend but um you know comedy people
are coming out families of like Gilbert
Godfrey's family came out nice respects
Rodney's family
shut up and Jeff Ross was like so who
are you guys and she was like I'm
Rodney's daughter whoa oh Ray nice and
who are these people and there's like
these older kids and he's like these are
my kids and then Jeff starts roasting
them in Rodney's voice wow with Rodney's
material wow he's like hey you have any
kids who lived I mean like just kept
harping at least you know she wasn't
two-faced she'd be wearing her other
face he was doing this to his family
were they loving it no
the arms molded oh yeah I just picture
eight kids in suits with a red tie
someone anime the whole time like yeah
it's Ross guys really bombing he's all
right no respect no respect I haven't
seen a bomb this bad since that guy got
blown in Ukraine
all right wow that's that's a wild sight
right there
what kids you got to realize the son or
daughter or whatever of a comic isn't a
comic you know like you ever seen Kelly
Carlin she's like a nice normal lady
George Carlin one of the greatest
comments of all time is his daughter
is she no but she gets comedy she's cool
she's cool I'm here to talk about comedy
she's very you know her observations are
astute she's a smart person she gets it
yeah but she ain't one of us which is a
different life it's a different life
that's what I'm saying it's not like
your wife has to be a comic
exactly damn it but yeah touche
I came home I see a guy jogging naked I
said sir why are you jogging naked he
goes because you came home early yeah
so my doctor said hey you gotta you got
cancer goes I want to get a second
opinion he goes all right you're ugly
too
classic
Rodney is the best yeah yeah he's an
ugly kid my mother never breastfeed me
she told me she'd like me as a friend
all right I was so ugly when I came out
they slapped my mother
I got no respect I used to share a
locker with a mop I tell you
that's a nice throwaway That's a classic
yeah oh I love all dude all those
[ __ ] old uh all those old Rodney
[ __ ] dude he gives me hope because
everybody goes uh comedy doesn't age
well it rarely ages well and Rodney
those tonight shows still hold up all
the jokes are Timeless and they have
like millions of views which I love I
love that young people are like wow this
is funny yeah because they hate anything
old order for the bartender I said
surprise me he showed me a naked picture
of my wife I said who said he could
sleep with my wife he said everybody
wow that's a double that's a double
killer he's that one where he's like uh
my wife cut me down to sex once a week
some guys she cut out all together yeah
that's a great one brilliant uh I told
my wife she told me he wants to have sex
in the car and she wants me to drive
ah they still work they still work I'm
gonna talk during sex the other week she
called me from Chicago
I've never heard that one he's great
that's the killer he's the best and
they're so short and they can still
murder I'm sitting here with Spokane
nonsense and this guy's got a 20 in a
row like 11 seconds I asked if she
wanted a cigarette after sex she said no
thanks one drag's enough oh
he's great man now I'm now waiting to
pull it up but I will be here all night
I'll be here all day all right here or
no I'm not you've been all right sorry I
got my Rodney Tourette's going I love it
RT's all right folks thanks a lot we
might be drunk uh Happy New Year Bodega
catwhiskey.com see us on the road uh we
got merch for both Oklahoma City this
weekend then [ __ ] theater tour starts
baby so New Orleans Austin uh Dallas
Tulsa Tulsa St Louis my eyesight's
blurry Vegas Vegas Las Vegas lost wages
Vegas let's see Vancouver yeah battle
Portland February 4th big big Salt Lake
City uh Valentine's Day oh I'll never be
more alone in my life I'll tell you
Huntington Atlantic City Royal Oak yeah
that's nice uh Minneapolis all that [ __ ]
uh Boston had a fourth there so come out
please my schedule's all out of whack
here but uh I'm back in the clubs
because I need to build a new hour zany
is in Nashville we got like eight shows
ready to go love that that's [ __ ]
great then I'm going to Hawaii e blue
note tickets are not moving then Miami
Improv all kinds of fun day markdorman
comedy.com we're going back to Spokane
and then uh Jacksonville
uh I'm doing some rough ones Dayton
Toledo I'm running it through the mud
Funny Bone oh Church what are you doing
I don't know hey look at city of glass
man easy Fort Wayne on Thanksgiving
we don't love ourselves no no it's a
problem but yeah come on out I need you
to fill these rooms with our people so
it's not uh I'm not reminded I'm in
Toledo to lead to the type of room
you're going to the hotel you check the
ceiling fan to see how much weight I
could hold it
is that his no it's me that's right it's
me and Rodney's voice that's killer uh
yeah I'll kill myself
and uh yeah we'll see in Hell get some
merch get some Bodega beard you Mark
Norman voice suicide
uh beard you is at good room in
Greenpoint every Friday otherwise I
might say less and I'm in the U.S for
another month or so and then if you want
to meet me somewhere in Southeast Asia
hit me up oh yeah interesting you're
gonna be the tallest you're gonna be
like Model boys
what'd you say you hear that 14 year old
boy oh yeah he's gonna be grabbing them
like the end of the Hidden Temple
anything anything to promote Salamanca
uh no I'm just shooting this Caroline's
last days doc I can't wait to see that
can't wait to see it's gonna be great
excited for you a classic uh Club so uh
we're sorry to see it Go Carolina's but
we can't wait to see we end up and and
thanks for all the all the gigs over the
years and all the free drinks and
chicken parms We Appreciate You Hell
yeah yeah yeah you I think we both won
contest there I think I came in second
me too I think we both lost guns oh yeah
good point I lost the soda it was a
great night though I still had fun I
stole fun losing the Dan because he's
great and he's a good friend so it was a
fun night yeah those Christmas parties
my God great time I still remember uh
Rich Voss spin kicking Jason Cantor and
breaking the ribs yeah crazy good
parties parties broke his ribs all right
those are the days you guys you good
we'll see you all day guys we'll see you
soon thank you
comedy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I get down in the same way
[Music]